Hey, this is kind of interesting.
So a couple of weeks ago I told you that for
a while I've been mulling over how could we
introduce a Spanish language version of the
David Pakman show into the online political
mil youth, so to speak.
The idea being there's lots of people in the
United States whose English is not good enough
to really take in a political content like
the normal English language version of the
David Pakman show.
Uh, so if there was some way to do a version
of the David Pakman show in Spanish, we would
be reaching a completely new audience.
Now it's not practical.
I don't have the time in the day in the literal
sense to do the entire show over in my native
language of Spanish remembering of course
that I was born in Argentina and learned English
as a second language.
So one idea that I presented a couple of weeks
ago was doing a computer s uh, like an automated
computer overdub of the show in a computerized
Spanish voice.
And the problem was it sounded pretty unnatural.
Let me play a little bit of that for you just
to remind you.
[inaudible] Hey, [inaudible] Lanka, Donald
Trump, [inaudible] Washington Post, probably
two AIDS [inaudible] mass locals.
I see Chris how ago The Washington Post Escribio
[inaudible] Trump, El Domingo, Cassie [inaudible],
[inaudible] Washington [inaudible], you know,
the [inaudible] stays here equally the Washington
Post.
So I asked for feedback on that and the feedback
was almost unanimous.
I mean, it's a, I can't think of any time
when feedback has been so overwhelmingly United
on anything.
People were overwhelmingly positive about
the idea of a Spanish version of the David
Pakman show.
But the consensus was that auto dub technology
is not the way to do it.
It's just not, not dynamic enough.
It doesn't sound anything like the program
or like me with dynamics in my speech.
So I tabled it because the alternative is
to get a real person to dub every day.
What we're doing that's expensive.
It's a ton of work and maybe it's outside
of our scope.
Cut to this week when a reddit user and a
viewer of the show actually did a real dub
of a David Pakman show clip.
Now the time it took us crazy, it took him
four hours for like a two or three minute
clip.
Um, but it's actually really good.
So take a look at this.
Take a listen.
This isn't even a, um, uh, it's, it's sort
of funnier in a sense because this was a voicemail
segment from the ag man and he translates
ag man as [inaudible].
Literally egg man.
I mean, as a literal translation, I just don't
know why I find that hilariously endearing.
We'll play just a little bit of a, of this.
Take a listen.
Then [inaudible] is a number that's [inaudible]
estimates.
[inaudible] the [inaudible] [inaudible] that's
pretty much [inaudible] Medica [inaudible]
[inaudible] Obamacare.
Look [inaudible] Elysium to win the ball game.
I love it.
I truly have no idea how we could make this
a thing, but I think it does have potential.
The, the reality is, you know, professional
daily dubbing of the entire show would be,
I think extraordinarily expensive.
The idea is not to fill our current channel
with Spanish language content, but my, my
thought was to create, you know, the David
Pakman show in Spanish and to have Spanish
versions of our clips there.
Um, also part of why this is funny to me is
that me being from Argentina, my Spanish accent
is so different from this viewer who's from
somewhere, not Argentina or Udo Gueye.
They don't sound like they're from Spain.
I can't quite place the accent.
It doesn't sound Puerto Rican or Dominican,
but it sounds could be anything from Mexico
to Colombia or Venezuela, something like that.
That's also just kind of funny to me, although
I guess it'd be less funny the people who
don't speak Spanish anyway, let me know what
you think about this.
I think it is a very, very cool idea.
Uh, I mean I think like the dream would be
someone in Argentina can give us some really
great rate on dubbing the entire day's clips.
So it would be in an Argentinian accent, maybe
because of the exchange rate, it would be
more affordable.
I don't know.
Um, in any case, I really appreciate this
one clip being dubbed and a really, really
nice job.
If you have other ideas for what we might
be able to do on this, let me know.
I think that there is value.
And listen, this is not just, I mean I think
to be very clear, I actually think that the
value of doing this type of content in Spanish
but for American politics is that we could
really be reaching an entire new audience
that doesn't feel like they have content like
this that is in their wheelhouse, wheelhouse
linguistically based on the level at which
they do, or maybe don't speak English.
So there's tons of programs in Argentina,
in Spanish about Argentinian politics.
There's tons of programs, programs in Mexico,
in Spanish about Mexican politics.
But my idea is that this is really an untapped
market.
I mean, I don't know that any of the other
progressive online shows are even thinking
about this.
I'm thinking about it because I'm an immigrant
from Argentina and I talked to so many people
all the time, just people I meet out in the
world who would love to be following American
politics in Spanish from a progressive perspective,
but there is not as much available as maybe
they would like.
So I'm actually seeing this as an activism
tool in addition to just being kind of interesting
and different.